hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the fastest mac mini in the
world giveaway let's go so for those of
you who are new here at the beginning of
the year i did a four part video series
where i took the latest generation 2012
mac mini and took it to the absolute max
in this video series we took the highest
end available mac mini and then took it
even further by installing the fastest
single ssd solution that the mac could
handle and installing the most and
fastest possible ddr3 ram 16 gigs of ram
that the mac mini can handle so the end
result was a boss just an absolutely
ridiculously fast mac so this is a
collaboration giveaway with lou as you
probably already know him unbox therapy
he has uploaded a video similar to this
and all you need to do to get entered to
win this boss is to leave a comment
right below the like button on this
video commenting on this video is one
entry whether you leave one comment or
50 it gets your name into the pool same
with the unbox therapy video so if you
want to double your chances of winning
this machine then you can leave a
comment on this video and on the unbox
therapy video which should be the first
link in the description and you have now
two entries to win this mac mini so be
sure to go ahead and do that and once
you do you can just sit back relax
you've entered and the winner will be
announced in exactly one week so on the
next monday we'll be announcing the
winner the comments will close and it'll
be announced in a live stream so
hopefully that'll be exciting for you
guys and all the giveaway details and
the entry details for what time that's
going to take place will be on twitter
so in case you're wondering what's been
powering my setup after the mac mini
i've actually made a bit of an upgrade
so i'll be giving a full setup tour as
my next video so be sure to subscribe if
you want to see something like that and
uh that's about it so thanks good luck
best of luck for you guys who are
entering more than once and i'll talk to
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching see you around
peace
[Music]
you